Overlay Networks is a general principle and at
the OS level we already have an overlay network.
There is the IP Network which is really
an overlay on top of the local area network.
You may have a particular IP address for
your laptop. That IP address actually translates to a
Mac address. Because the Mac address is the real
address that is used by the physical network in
the local area network to communicate with other buddies
on the same local area network. So at the
OS level, when you send a message using TCP/IP,
that message, it will be delivered to your buddy who
happens to be on the same local area network.
It is actually getting converted to a Mac address so
that it can traverse the local area network and
get to the desired destination. So that it can traverse
the local area network and get to the
desired destination. Similarily, CDN, a content distribution network is
an overlay on top of TCP/IP. So in particular, In the case of CDN, we have this
node ID. There is some manufactured ID at
the application level, but that maps to an IP
address, and that is how at the application level,
when I say I want to send a message
to Node number 60, at the application level, I can convert that Node ID 60 to
an IP address. To which I can send
it and eventually the message will get delivered.